AT THE END OF THE ROAD TRIP IN
MONTREAL.
A 6-3 WIN AGAINST DROP.
AND OH, RIGHT TO THE
FRONT.
HE'S STOPPED OPPOSITION'S
GOGO BOD
HIT A BODY IN FRONT, 1-0 SHARKS
AND THAT IS A POWER PLAYS1.
>> Tyson: WHAT I PLAY, I THINK
TH
6'3".
235 POUNDS OFE AND A
STOP BY VEJMELKA.
>> Tyson: OWE, WHAT A MOVE IS
RIGHT.
THAT WAS GOAL.
NO QUESTION, KICKS IT U WORK.
ALL THE INJURIES FOR THE COYOTES
THEY HAVE TO M TURNOVER, JAN
WHEELHOUSE BANG-BANG PLAY, AND T
HIGH AND IT'S CLEARED UP.
>> Tyson: WHAT A SAVE FRAME, 6'E
NET.
VIEL BACK HAPPEN.
THAT'S J J IN AND BEATS
VEJMELKA.
AND JUST LIKE THAT, THE SHARKS
HAVE DROPPED RIGHT PIPE.
TOMÁS HERTL LYUBUSHKIN THAT'S
THE OPPORTUNITIESP
THE THIRD PERIOD OF P KELLER.
OUT HIGH.
SCHMALTZ, HIS SHOT JUST WIDE OFF
THE END BOARDS TOENAIL ON THAT .
DENIED.
MEGNA CAN'T CLEAR IT, THE
COYOTES HAVETENDER TO TRARA
COUTURE, S HIS FIRST OF TTOPPEDL
AS WELL.
PIPE.!
JAN JENIK HE IT.
BACKHAND,GET TO PUCK,
ERIC KARLSSON TO THE ALMOST END,
SOMEHOW BOYD GOT HIM THE BUCK.
IT'S SHUFF ICES IT.
IT'S